[Music]
foreign
smiling through the cold but normally
Samara and her colleagues at this school
for pupils with special needs would be
inside
they want a pay rise that meets the
rising cost of living and keeps people
in the profession
I've had to make huge sacrifices I've
actually worked two jobs and for five
years now to be able to literally keep a
roof over my head and to be able to put
fuel in my car so that I can actually
get to work even friends of mine who
have been teachers for two three years
have decided that it's just not for them
because they genuinely cannot bear the
stress and the the overload um and the
workload that they are expected to do
thousands of teachers and their families
marched in London on Wednesday many
stress pay Rises should be far higher
than the five percent offered for last
year and be paid for by the government
not come from already stretched School
budgets
that five percent pay came out of school
budgets so what you're doing is you're
taking away glue sticks in order to be
in order to pay your teachers and that's
not good enough my mum's a teacher and
we come home and like it's just she
works so much so much longer than she
should have to and they're being paid so
like they're doing so much more than
they're required to
well these teachers are making sure
their demands are heard on what is
clearly a sizable demonstration here in
London but they're also part of a wave
of industrial action taking in various
parts of the economy all calling on the
government for pay Rises that meet
inflation
the government insists it's bound by the
recommendations of the pay review body
even though it's constrained by the
financial remit ministers gave it the
independent pay review body recommended
five percent for experienced teachers
and 8.9 for new teachers there's also
progression pay within those salary bans
as well so 40 of classroom teachers will
actually be getting pay Rises up to 15.9
this year for the National Education
Union that's far from good enough they
accuse Ministers of refusing meaningful
talks they've got to
dial down the rhetoric dial down the
anti-union anti-teacher tone they've got
to stop doing political stunts they've
got to get into a room and they got to
vote the time and resources to
negotiating the settlement so at the
moment there is not an offer on the
table that you can put to them no
there's no extra money for this year and
indeed they delayed they should have
published their evidence to the pay
review body on Friday and haven't
published it
the next education strike is due at the
end of the month if there's no movement
on pay we're likely to be seeing more
protests not just from people like
Samara but workers in other key
professions who at least for now enjoy
broad support from the public Nadine
barber Al Jazeera London